The rumble. Johnson fight was a
tough one for you to swallow too,
because it was in Stockholm.
It was this enormous event.
Everybody was there to see you.
And I'm in that fight.
We didn't pick it up while the fight was
going on. But you guys collided heads.
Yeah. Yeah. It was a
head. But yeah, I'm not,
I'm not taking anything away
from Anthony Johnson hit.
That guy is a beast and he hits a hot,
he's one of the hardest hit her in the,
in the no fucking sport. No doubt. I mean,
no one's taking anything away from him.
He's truly exceptional. But the thing
is, I would throwing my, my, my,
my kick there and he just came in
there and he's forehead hit my,
my chin. Yeah. And from, and
I just, I just blacked out.
I didn't, I went down, I went up again. I
was in the Ma, I was in the match again.
He just, you know, we need to get a
taste of blood. He just goes for it.
And I should just keep my guard
up. I'm, I'm very like this. Right.
And I'm very lengthy and he just
caught me as I'm doing all that. Well,
this is not one of those situations
where until you've been there and you,
you been that hurt in a big fight
like that. It's like the experiences,
it's an alien experience.
It is. It is. It's, it's,
you don't recognize any of it.
It's like you can't,
nothing controls your mind
trying to control your legs,
your arms like this and that. But it was
just, I was just disoriented and man,
it was four in the morning in
one of the big stadium in Sweden,
four in the morning. We fill it
up, we fill it up, and it's huge.
It was huge, man. And, and, and, uh, and
like I said, four in the morning, I do,
you know, when the people told me like,
oh, we're going to do this. I'm like, no,
he's not gonna. It's not gonna happen. How
should we manage to fill this place up?
Right.
But still people went there to see it.
It was just amazing
feeling stepping out there.
Well for people that don't
understand why they did it,
to coordinate it with American
paper view. Yeah, exactly. Exactly.
So yeah, that was it. That was
it. Yeah. It was rough, man.
It was a rough loss.
And now rumble just decided he
doesn't want to fight anymore,
which is kind of crazy. Yeah. Every
now and then he thinks about it.
He says he wants to come back
as a heavyweight, Huh? Yeah.
I don't think he was even going
to make it to light heavy anymore.
Now he's suspicious.
I've seen,
it's so crazy to think that
that guy fought at one 70
at one point in his career.
I can't even, I can't even,
I can't even see that. Now.
I can understand how even did it,
I mean, it's just such a mess.
His neck is like the size of his
head and he has no small head.
He has like this big round head and neck
is the size of his head. So he's now,
he's a big guy. I really, big guy.
I ran into him once while
he was fighting one 70. Uh,
he was in the lobby of a hotel. I
came downstairs and I go, Anthony,
how much do you weigh? And he's
laughing. He's like, dude, 30 I was like,
two 30 you weighed two 30 you got it.
That makes my week.
I they see, I'm telling
them, I mixed my wake at my,
it makes my week at easy. I'm
not, his weight cut was horrific.
He used to his whole, his cheeks, she's
just sucking. He has prominent cheekbones.
Right. So like when his weight
cut was fully dehydrated,
when his body was like, really? It
was like horrible. It was like, look,
go a skeleton. Oh Shit. It's like, man,
that's an echo for you had all missed
wait a bunch of times to, no, no.
I'm going up to like takeaways.
He's probably the best thing he's ever
done in his career. I agree. Yeah. Yeah.
I was Kinda stunned when he decided to
retire, but what he said was interesting.
He said, uh, I'm not a fighter.
He goes, I'm an athlete. He goes,
I'm just really good at fighting.
How does it, I don't like fighting.
I don't know if that's correct though.
I would say more like,
I like it like a fighter, you
know, he's a great athlete, but,
but I see him more like a, like a
hardcore fighter. I don't, you know,
we are all athletes doing this, but, but
he's more like the fighter, you know,
Phil Davis is, he's an athlete. He's an
athlete. But this guy, he's just like,
it's a fireman.
I'm telling you.